oh the honest the only supplement
company I'll go with because your MCT
oil is great but I just because I know
Rogan takes it and I know Rogen's you
cannot listen to Joe how much to take no
we did this funk streamis the cyborg if
you take his face off there's his
propellers and why're we we did we did
that 10 seamen being on all eight he
smoked weed and got more successful yeah
well we did the podcast where they
talked about already dosing me and I was
still having problems with my serotonin
levels there was it was [ __ ] up for a
while but it was like the it was the
like three days after it happened and I
still was having hardcore panic attacks
and I wasn't right yet and just like
just take a little love new mood and I
was like and I know that stuff works and
I was like you have somebody's account
right here and he opened up my home and
he's like take four maybe six for sex
you're a bigot so I take four and then
he goes Jarritos I might take somebody
gives it to Arion or he's like it says
take two with a meal and Joe's a guy you
don't need that or he put his back or
you dosed me and put his back in the
case because I'm gonna hold off that
night I'm sitting at home going I feel a
little [ __ ] aggressive like there's
too much serotonin going on I bet my god
but yeah I fight over petting your call
yeah I don't know man I'm always afraid
of everything I took one here whatever
wheat he smokes
I took one hit today I had to have shop
come and pick me up at the studio and
take me to his house I ate a steak I was
still high it took me six hours to be
able to get my hair he is I'm sorry yeah
the guy on set yeah on set okay
yeah it's not set okay now because
because father times your barber what
does that mean oh you know exactly no I
want to know it all the time gives you a
nice thing is it off the top things are
starting it out the back things are
thinning out on the top my head like
Friar Tuck and I understand other time
is thinning out your shirt I got a I got
a paint it he's gonna give you a nice
little birds nest up he's got yep but
we're a daddy's gonna go ahead and get
himself another hair transplant I have
to classic I'm surprised we're coming
here with a full head of hair and
beautiful [ __ ] eyes with no skin who
I'd love that on it yep and then and a
whole new look
yeah but that might be Mason right there
that's that's the worst
guys just don't give it up when it's
just like right here and you see a bald
a like did you just draw attention she's
gotta have some vanity a little vanity
and fashion sense the guy does my hair
is a gay man but still he his beard he
wears a sweater a certain way he's got
he's got the earrings but everything
about him he is considered it's all
considered as that [ __ ] now he's a
married man all right now you take it
easy
oh all right man as a gay dude yeah
what's up means married to is yeah well
two guys you guys who bros I told you
that you were married yeah I mean you'll
never marry like dude I saw this [ __ ]
guy on the bus and I just
you'd be like bring him home and I'll
wrestle him yeah and efficient let's
spit for him yeah well there is a there
isn't this is so gay why don't we always
go get by a car in Marina del Rey I was
walking my dog one night and I just saw
a big ass just going up and down the
cars beyond yeah was it dark yeah it was
dark was it with it with it with it
tinted windows yeah but all I could see
was that [ __ ] ass a big hairy guy
who's big strong oh my god that's a big
ass oh my god tee's come on
I couldn't get oh and I don't want it I
couldn't linger because I didn't want to
be I don't want to invade their privacy
now if you haven't seen so one second
quite some time sites on the tube yeah
I'm sure you guys heard about this
already the mountain lion attack on a
three-year-old boy weird it's in a lake
forest
it's a wildlife park and we click force
in Orange County
holy [ __ ] raintree's there's in Lake
Forest yep well widen gradual this park
children and you know six-year-old was
that was hiking with her parents in
Colorado yeah mountain lion came down
shraddh the child and disappeared they
never saw a child lucky for this one the
dad caught it in time so they'll take a
child and take yeah well you know what I
don't know where I live there's a like a
it's like a dog park to the beginning of
a walking trail and there's signs all
over please keep your job posting
mountain lions and my mistakes yeah
don't [ __ ] around with no child's not
safe in mountain lion hold hands
Taiyo ds2 coyotes if they're alone yeah
you know
[ __ ] around that but especially mount
lines mountain lions well children will
get eaten do you rent that mountain lion
ate those bikers yeah that I think is in
Washington right what happened attack
the bike they attack the bikers and then
they attacked one and then the one firm
was like oh [ __ ] dude good luck I'm
gonna good help ran away mountain lion
thing where the [ __ ] you going dumbass
ate him alive I'll kill him and all they
found was the skull white he dragged to
a whole body up to the thing they found
the guys skull I didn't know that they
killed something like that there was
something like that really exactly like
the mountain like you killed the
mountain for doing mountain lion [ __ ]
yeah though only the best part is the
one guy who ditched it yeah that's the
food good luck bro we gonna get help he
killed that guy got killed the other guy
survived Jesus because cuz he ran away
in the mountain lion go yeah yeah and
then the best ride they were best
friends and they found out his friend
was a piece of [ __ ] cuz gonna leave him
to die and then he had to do than
press-conference me like you know Jerry
was brave and a trustworthy friend but
you just tell you [ __ ] they said a
mountain lion can jump the length of a
bus like that's that's a long death a
lot well I don't know because I saw a
tiger do that that's all you ever see a
tight you see a tiger attack the guy on
the he just keeps flying
yeah just keeps going sorry yeah yeah it
is it is out for what in the yeah bound
up to 40 feet running leap 15 feet up a
tree climb over a 12-foot know they
they're crazy they can jump a 12-foot
fence well they'd so that there was a
photonic in amount line jump over a bus
for me the length of of us the length of
a bus so no they not saying they jump
over a bus they can jump 45 feet
horizontally over is crazy bust a long
way that's what says this means they can
jump over school bus the long way this
says is if you actually believe this
you're an idiot
well no wait come on yeah unread so in
other words they can't start at down the
floor and jump over that's how hey Dave
right but if they were running as long
jump they can they can cover that much
distance maybe that seems a long way to
20 yeah right 23 but also [ __ ] not mine
not even [ __ ] animal so you killing
kids and [ __ ]
yeah we don't need him around joke I'm
everyone was all up in arms when we got
hit on the 405
hey max predators but they leave people
alone their own shot hey
but they was it's very rare yeah really
good kid you know so when that one got
hit on the 405 thing but a very similar
I'm trying to cross the [ __ ] smoke a
light is hiking three years old though
that's like Tiger that's a baby
oh dude Tiger is big yeah all right
[ __ ] Mountain life but he grabbed him
by the neck and started dragging away
the father caught in time through a
backpack at him and then he took the
backpack and took up a tree that's what
you see in the back over here so they're
pretty damn sure this is the cat so they
found the authorities and they killed
them gotta kill me yeah assume right in
the face you're not in danger now
they're they're thriving out here yeah
that's why when you hit one in the 405
that should give you [ __ ] bonus point
they're everywhere those stupid things
you know they're gonna make a crosswalk
yeah from it from Santa Monica to like
Brentwood well cuz they have to cross
the highways yeah but they didn't make
it
yeah so now they try they try to cross
the 405 you know here's a could be bro
science could also save your life if you
do see one on the 405 or a moose you
know you don't slow down
you know why you speed up so they go
over the roof not through that's right
interesting so if you see a mountain
lion [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] up try to hit
it yeah try it well hit in the air speed
speed I got a Tesla though I got a low
no sing about my you know my show was
why I'm gonna find the world's best
dancing dog that sounds like I said
first night my fur this business
production talk my first night we got a
buck or a little production meeting with
the director the producers the writers
everyone and I was like guys and I'm
like they're like you wanna beer and I
was like no no no we gotta work tomorrow
and they're like yeah I want to have a
beer and I was like guys I want to be on
my my game I want to make sure this gets
picked up and this one guy I'll just
call Mike cuz I said name he goes really
and I want what he goes do you wanna
spend the rest of your life looking for
dancing dogs or do you want to just
maybe gonna make an okay show hope it
doesn't get picked up and get paid know
it yeah I don't want to look for dancing
dogs cuz I have a [ __ ] beer and I was
like by the way I had the best time
shooting that show ever I would work
with those guys every dancing [ __ ]
dog and by the way we meant to expert
with the world's best dancing dog and it
was so lackluster or we spent the whole
show is about finding the best and the
expert the best
dog lady it was such a lackluster
performance that the cameramen were
doubled over going this is what we've
been looking for
it was so [ __ ] bad we watched two
horses [ __ ] that day and that was way
more interesting these animals that's so
dangerous once they grapple onto
something they have in their mind that
like oh this is prey you're not getting
away the power isn't overwhelming I
fought a bear one time I don't know if
that's true Burt when was this I need to
get a bear okay nice hear you done 2002
you don't know the exact date no I was a
TV show well what kind of bear was it
just up to five up to five I did God
okay you say sweat God tried tamed lions
that day hold on what kind of bear was
part of grizzly big [ __ ] drivers
named bamboo okay see
I've been bambam the bear another five
so you fought you fought a [ __ ] woods
you didn't go revenant DiCaprio against
Lee I really did do this I really did no
I'm being serious wouldn't you rest on
the bear so they it was a it's a bear
that was in like it's a movie bear and
so they were like yeah you can wrestle
him so I go up for the show I had heard
Burt and they're like all right here we
go they're paper I'm a grizzly bear
there you go so and they go all right
he's gonna I think I wrestled BAM Bam's
mom if I'm not mistaken and so they put
his on her arms on your on your
shoulders she grabbed on to my ears and
the second I felt just a a smidge of her
power
I went oh I'm helpless like you didn't
you don't realize you always think
you've got some kind of shot in your
head in the wild you like bear shows up
my kids I stand in front of my kids I'd
go for the Bears like you think of some
dude or food you've heard about I mean I
can't believe they let you was a bushy
muzzled no they just let you wrestle
with a jack wrestled a [ __ ] bear I
would never do that I tamed lions that
same day and man the the subtlest the
when you see that instinct click over
and you watch them go like like when I
went went to fight lions they were like
are they're like how do you tame lions
and they go oh here take this fanny pack
full of sirloin in this plunger stick
with a nail in it and they're like
that's your meat stick don't drop it
put meat on the tip of the meat stick
they'll they'll pay attention why the
plunger
or that it's not-it's just a pond your
stick Oh like I pictured like a plunger
with the nail coming out of it suction
it align think about the thing about
animals when you are around a wild
animal I think it's all stained because
for human beings is something about
we're very self-centered as people even
if you're a giving person you think of
yourself as a human mm-hmm you think of
yourself as the top of the food chain
one way or another when you are with an
animal I pet a cheetah one time and any
kind of them like that you realize that
they don't care about you that they that
you are so insignificant to them when
you see my back rippling I pull myself
up like a champ
like a chimp 30 times fast while talking
to you why wouldn't I give that to you
as it's a gift it's a gift it's a gift